hi I'm Ross Butler I'm Alicia and I'm
Brandon Flynn no last name for Alicia
juice you're Alicia I'm trying to like
become fun oh yeah beyond thing someday
I'm just trying to pink Alicia
and where was BuzzFeed and we're gonna
talk about our first times first
impression of Brandon and Ross my first
impression of Brandon was that I thought
you were kind of a dick and I know we
weren't really gonna get along but there
we are
you're stuck with me no I'm stuck with
you for life and bras I think we started
like working out together first yeah and
yeah that's how we broke through then we
ended up going to a video game
convention good first impression Alicia
you were I didn't I just didn't think
we'd get along but that's all changed
and then Ross I'm just kind of
intimidated by you because you were so
like I'm you're like a man's man like
and I wasn't wrong oh I think we worked
out together - and we had like does like
working out but you had a full bar - at
your house yeah cool every time I think
of you I just think of like whiskey and
good tequila okay Ross um so much person
Brendan yeah we got along like right off
the bat yeah because we were doing
sports together and and all that so in
our in our friend we were friends in the
show yeah so Alicia's laughs first
season neighbors yeah literally woke up
neighbors like we can I tell me
elevators - yes so the first season we
were all living in the same we were all
living in the same apartment complex we
all hang out and we'd like leave the
windows open cuz for AC and Alicia's
laugh no joke
it's what used to be so loud yeah we got
into the elevator one day and one of the
neighbors was like hey did you hear that
last night like somebody was just
screaming like no
no idea what you're talking about and
they got off the elevator
obviously that day I was like I need to
change the way I laugh so I really I was
I've worked on it and I'm getting better
it was like I don't know how you would
describe it was like a scream category I
can do it but so much I don't want to
blow my god home with a good laugh first
memory that comes to mind from the set
of 13 reasons why they might first see
never lose me and Stephen silver even
pulling up in my Audi convertible so
like tell Dylan to get in be like hey
we're gonna drive you see the one you've
so hot and they put me in a shirt a
sweater another me yeah so I was
thinking a winter coast a first seat
like the first episode I was in so hot
yeah is we're shooting like fall yeah so
I'm at all four so yes remember the
makeup like I because I just remember
like that first day like the guy they
just put so much red under my ow
that they had to end up going back and
like color I think and you have the fake
temple as a disclaimer in the second
episode those not a real piece where
they put a fake pimple on me it's like
making me seem stress or something first
thing you do when you're preparing for a
new role read the script I don't
remember my new name so I can like like
walk by the mirror be like Jessica's
like I'll just get sad
you know I feel like every character has
something sad to think about so I'll
just be sad and be like why my side
first three actually I thought you read
the word or a book of 13 reasons why I
read the book in middle school so it
felt like it was very I don't know it
really did teach me like you never know
what else what someone is going through
and I found myself applying that to my
14 year old brain at the time
so it was very yeah it's ringing fine
home for sure I hadn't read the book
before but when I was driving up the
Santana for the first season I listened
to the audiobook and it's actually the
perfect length like right when I parked
there there's like the book ended it was
perfect imagine you like it and be like
well I remembered reading might like the
Justin's sides like the scenes that they
gave me for his audition and I really
have I called my agent at the time I was
like this is awesome the script is the
best one we've gotten so far first big
purchase after getting your first major
role I think my my car a little mini
coop I don't know big spinner unless
it's food like I think the biggest thing
was I just felt more comfortable
spending more money on food yeah yeah
like good food mine was a car but I like
was still I just did we didn't I didn't
grow up that way so like I my first
paycheck I was like whoa let me save a
bunch and then I bought like a $7000 a
ten-year-old Prius by the time I got I
had it for a year and it was like it was
2,000 miles on first job when I was a
kid I used to live in apartment complex
and it snowed in Virginia a lot so I
would charge people a dollar to wipe all
the snow off their cars oh that's good
and I sometimes I would do it first and
then pressure them into giving me the
dollar that's smart 11 years old at a
gas station in the Everglades oh my lord
oh god what were you doing were you like
pumping gas my dad was like managing the
Delhi part of it so I would go in it was
during one of the hurricanes so I saw
like the like insanity of people at I
don't know if you guys have ever
experienced that gas stations become
like the yeah hub like I was trying to
get gas in their car water for
generators
so it's like hundreds of cars lined up
it was like off of a freeway as well
yeah I was in the Brad's commercials
it's really fun why would you keep that
with a Barbie or nina brun